Мене звати Мар'яна Вольська, мені 27 років.
Я переїхала зі Львова до Сєвєродонецька наприкінці грудня 18-го року.
Тут я працюю у школі.
Також я є організаторкою "Україномовного розмовного клубу".
Уже понад рік Мар'яна Вольська після роботи у школі
двічі на тиждень поспішає до своїх дорослих учнів.
На зустрічі "Україномовного розмовного клубу" в офіс волонтерської організації "Восток SOS"
до неї щоразу приходять близько двадцяти мешканців Сєвєродонецька.
А деякі люди, щоб поспілкуватися українською,
добираються у столицю вільної Луганщини навіть із сусіднього Лисичанська.
Я рада всіх вас бачити. Наше попереднє заняття було дуже емоційним.
Було дуже багато коментарів, думок, бажань висловити свою думку.
Якщо у когось є ще якісь невисловлені думки -
те, що дуже хотілося сказати, то, будь ласка, зробіть це зараз.
Сьогодні у клубі говорять про внутрішніх переселенців.
Багатьом учасникам їхні проблеми відомі не з чуток.
Хтось допомагав біженцям як волонтер.
А хтось і сам втік з окупації.
Я - переміщена особа. Я заїхав у Северодонецьк, і я...
дуже вдячний місцевим людям небайдужим. Вони дійсно допомагали нам.
Ми переїхали, ви нас прийняли - теж змінились, ми змінились.
Багато що змінилось у житті.
Луганчанин Віталій - поліцейський.
У 2014-му році він з двома дІтьми і дружиною
виїхав з рідного міста, яке захопили бойовики "ЛНР".
Відтоді вирішив перейти на українську - спілкується нею і вдома, і на роботі в поліції.
Коли я починав розмовляти в родині українською,
це було не дуже мелодійно, скажімо так, і слова були такі - суржик.
Не дуже приємно було слухати. Вони казали: "Ой, дуже тяжко тебе сприймати".
Через те, що я розмовляю в клубі, мова стала більш мелодійною.
У мене так - я починаю з себе, а коли в мене воно вже піде, мої рідні теж будуть переходити.
У мене в Сєвєродонецьку були такі ситуації, коли я звертався українською мовою,
а мені казали: "Звертайся, будь ласка, до мене російською, тому що я тебе так не сприймаю.
Я звик до тебе, коли ти розмовляєш російською мовою".
Місць, де можна було би поспілкуватися українською, у Сєвєродонецьку майже немає.
Крім "Україномовного розмовного клубу", чи не єдина така локація - кафе "Львівські круасани",
де обслуговування державною мовою - політика закладу.
Доброго дня.
- Чи можна замовити середнє лате?
- Так, можна.
До сплати - 26 гривень.
Дуже приємно приходити час від часу і чути,
коли до тебе без "будь ласка" звертаються українською мовою.
Явних конфліктів через те, що я спілкуюсь українською
або я з іншого регіону, жодного разу не було.
Я можу сказати, що є якесь, можливо, емоційне ставлення до цього.
До прикладу, коли ти приходиш в магазин і
три рази говориш назву якогось продукту,
яка написана українською мовою, але тебе спонукають сказати її російською,
це трішечки неприємно.
Через нестачу україномовного контенту на Луганщині Мар'яна Вольська
і "Україномовний розмовний клуб" самі організовують
культурні події і міні-фестивалі у Сєвєродонецьку.
Вже відзначали традиційне українське Різдво, шевченківські дні і свято Івана Купала.
Такий собі культурний обмін між Заходом і Сходом.
Для мене це дуже крутий досвід.
дуже хотіла дізнатися більше про східні регіони і ніколи не мала такої можливості.
Я ніколи не спілкувалася раніше зі сходянами, і зараз для мене це більше ніж можливість.
Це відчуття якоїсь власної відповідальності за те, що тут відбувається.
Я бачу, що тут є потреба в знайомстві з тим, хто я є або ким я був,
ким були мої батьки або що таке українське.
Воно має бути потребою, звісно.
Таку потребу відчуває і Оксана Чіпіжна.
Сєвєродонеччанка саме почала ходити на зустрічі клубу - вивчати рідну мову.
Я ще не стала україномовною - я тільки намагаюся.
Я опановую цю мову - вона мені рідна, близька.
Я завжди себе відчувала українкою, тому що мій батько українець,
моя бабуся була україномовною, вона мене доглядала до року в дитинстві,
співала мені українські пісні.
Отакі клуби дають суспільству мовний розвиток.
Бажано, щоб їх було більше в місті.
Про створення подібних клубів в інших містах Луганщини
мріє й організаторка "Україномовного розмовного клубу"
у Сєвєвродонецьку Мар'яна Вольська.
Крім того, розповідає волонтерка,
вона зверталася до міської влади з пропозицією
допомогти чиновникам опанувати українську.
Утім, відповіді досі не отримала.
А на розширення поки не вистачає ресурсів.